which led her in 98 degree and if I'd
inverse now 15 probably
I will
Shakira machine and the Red Bull
for hostages
you should
No
I
election and the US adidas election
reform I just like
this issue artists in France and the
reason
why we chose the story for our
in france most immigrants come from
countries that were
the question of integration could be
around very long way for exampie name
memory also absence of such products as
Italy and France is heartened by
colonial past and there is a very
between academic studies on the names
look at me
organization
or instead of giving
French organism we we deal with
adversity as the bus which doesn't pass
away and there is a strong relation
between this us at doesn't pass away and
the 20 discourses of integration and I
will describe
on the one hand
permission
such as
of the humans
there is also a public discourse that
expresses the window product our city
yes what is suppose is a home
and the political
trust reviews Russell
using
which protects immigrants
really on the other hand
for the last five years the fragile
government has been developing a
politics of your injection
and
attributing criminality to minimize an
increase
edition of illegal immigrants and the
prediction of
yes the depart a shin of gypsies even
should be free where they change the
submission of the Night
creations not string and I
Immigration Department the realization
of activity may
and the dragon
french citizenship for recently
Jesus where they are convicted of Saturn
more generally we could accept what the
Patrick plan
so what
english the demonization
i nuts or is
click
love which
of the national government
forward and the graphics
police ID for each case if they will
give almonds the French citizenship they
have a discretionary power that they
directly to the size on immigrants and
according to
it expresses a loss of sobriety of
expression of the general will I
wouldn't want to say that it expresses
in a shoot away
director of the know it expresses also a
6,000 section of the French identity
recent immigrants have hit refresh and
Wellington values defined by the
Ministry of the integral
freedom and equality woman mondo garage
manners the office
remember they have to understand show
french island and all those measures
were justified by the government as
protecting
immigrants against the working class
setup program to reduce the number of
work
period but the fact is that equal
consider
people
that the most important problems are
buying forward communities in social
equality
and not regulation even when the world
was the extra party because we shall
bear explaining their words how this
xenophobia was developed and we are
I just would like to
that impression of immigration is at the
intersection of central social and
political stakes I would have to give
just one example to show that we need an
intersectional approach to immigration
this is no
auntie Becca
this law was passed a few months ago and
it worked well
us in order to risk our missing woman's
dignity and to protect them against new
zealand we're supposed and first level
to where the Ryoka most of those
are from the French experience in my
view ensure that our nice
well sis is labelled the parts and
catalase
and it shows our third answer that the
question of integration until today
proposition androscoggin ism restoration
of which general
that's why it's very sunny
we chose this topic for first level and
password
branch and the US political contest that
surrounds initial calculations in both
countries let me
I'm glad she wrote
this
researchers researchers at
Chancellorsville and professor Radisson
and she's the author of many books
including frontiers of US immigration
security
and Europe if with a professor
his most recent book is demo Castle
no you should
her and is the director of son would he
has not a beauty dish number of mind on
politics and it has a mission failure
accession center console and they have
published last month sometimes making
sure so much
and zoom
hold on yes
professor of political science at the
University and his most recent book is
Newton boxes letting us know
munitions
professor of history
we publish the gospel handbook of Latin
America
thank you
you